[Music]  i'm having visions  the body of dr florence weaver was found  brutally murdered in her home this  morning did you know her  no but i saw her die  [Music]  i'm seeing things  i'm seeing murders as they're happening  hello  he says his name is gabriel  i think he's someone from my past  happy birthday whatever happened to you  before you joined our family  hurt you in a way that i can't even  imagine  stop saying that maddie  who are you talking to gabriel  is he your imaginary imaginary friend  [Music]  he's the devil  whatever it was it's back  he killed again he's getting closer  he wants to talk to you  mom what do you know  he's coming from me  who are you gabriel  [Music]  [Music]  you